you
space the final frontier except we don't
have cool spaceships because the US
government has a bit of a thing for
aircraft carriers f-35s and ships
bristling with guns the united states
spends roughly six hundred billion
dollars per year on the military which
is about fifty four percent of the
annual discretionary budget by
comparison nasa only gets eighteen point
five billion dollars per year or were
less than 0.5% of the national budget
now we're not gonna get tied up in
debating whether or not the US needs
such a massive military but here are
some quick facts in case you're
interested the next biggest spender is
China at a hundred and ninety billion
dollars per year China has five hundred
of their type 99 tanks which are
outclassed by the m1 Abrams of which the
US has eighty seven hundred the US has
ten aircraft carriers the rest of the
world combined has ten smaller ones
there are eighty four hundred attack
helicopters around the world of these
the United States owns sixty four
hundred and those are just the vehicles
one single Tomahawk missile cost around
one-and-a-half million dollars then you
have paychecks fuel ammunition and all
the rest all those expenses add up to
that whopping figure of six hundred
billion dollars per year the general
public's interest in space exploration
has gradually dwindled since the space
race and now that there are no pesky
communists trying to steal the moon from
its rightful owners we haven't felt the
need to spend significant resources on
new missions but what if by some strange
turn of events NASA ended up with the
military's budget what could they do
with it for a little perspective the
entire cost of the Apollo program was
about a hundred thirty six billion in
two thousand seven dollars 136 billion
over thirteen years were just over ten
billion dollars per year picture a clock
representing six hundred billion dollars
one minute on that clock is ten billion
dollars one of the greatest scientific
achievements in history fits into that
tiny sliver of the US military budget
pretty crazy
we won't fuss about the little things
like bureaucracy and research and
development timelines in this video
we'll just think about the cool stuff
first NASA loves telescopes probes and
satellites with a massive budget the 10
or 20 years it would have taken to
launch all of their projects could be
cut down to just one or two years we
would see telescopes that make Hubble
seem like a Happy Meal toy
infrastructure upgrades could be
implemented to allow faster transmission
of data from new missions with all those
resources
orbit there would be new discoveries
much more frequently both on earth and
in the cosmos that could rekindle the
public's thirst for exploration possibly
the smartest decision NASA could make
would be to fund some smaller privately
owned space exploration groups like
SpaceX which has an excellent track
record of pushing the envelope they
could fund new space stations reusable
space planes asteroid mining operations
and lunar bases pushing further out into
science fiction territory once a lunar
base is established electromagnetic
launchers on the moon could put large
ships or space stations into lunar orbit
we're on a trajectory to Mars or beyond
that would definitely be the fastest way
to colonize Mars having sort of halfway
house on the moon to stage future
missions the International Space Station
cost about a hundred billion dollars
spread out over a decade so think of the
enormous highly advanced stations that
could be built with six times that
amount per year that kind of money and a
massive base of operations in orbit
could support a core of thousands of
active astronauts with a few hundred at
a time exploring the solar system in
different simultaneous missions serious
planning could begin for manned missions
into the Jovian system though it might
take several decades to become feasible
even with the massive budget then
there's this beast that NASA has been
putting off for years a rotating wheel
space station this design has been a
staple in science fiction and popular
speculation since the early 20th century
the rotation would provide artificial
gravity something prevalent in films
like 2001 a Space Odyssey but not yet
achieved in reality a giant rotating
wheel Space Station could be a mobile
base of operations near any planet we
wanted to colonize and could be used as
a safety net if something went wrong and
the colony had to be temporarily
evacuated or if multiple stations were
built they could be placed strategically
around the solar system as rest stops
for journeys into deep space
speaking of colonizing planets with a
six hundred billion dollar annual budget
it would be feasible to colonize Mars in
as little as 10 years if the entire
budget were spent on transporting people
and supplies to Mars and shared Rockets
in ten years we could potentially see a
population of 40,000 people or if NASA
wanted to test the waters before sending
a large population they could spend the
entire budget to send about 14 people
per year in their own individual rockets
and provide each person with over an
acre of Martian terrain to call their
own then there the intriguing celestial
bodies currently out of reach to mankind
we could send robotic explorers to them
all aircraft of Venus and Titan
submarines to Europa
imagine what discoveries could be made
in the vast oceans beneath Europa's icy
surface we could be just a few years
away from uncovering extraterrestrial
life if only NASA had the military's
pocketbook of course these are all
hypotheticals but with that kind of
funding to play with it's obvious that
the scientific world would be absolutely
inundated with mountains of new data and
offworld colonies could become a reality
easily within our lifetime and maybe
even interstellar travel who knows maybe
some Russian hackers will decide it's
time for another space race and switch
around some zeros in the national budget
a man can only dream if you enjoyed this
video please take a moment to subscribe
to my channel by clicking here it really
does help me provide great new content
every week leave a comment down below
with what you think NASA should spend
their giant budget on or to let me know
if I've missed anything you can check
out my previous video by clicking here
or a binge watch them all by clicking
here thanks for watching and I'll see
you next week
[Music]
[Music]